eu acho que gratidão que a gente não
demonstra que tenho é que nenhum
presente que a gente compra mas não
entrega não adianta nada
não sou extremamente grato porque nesse
palco
engraçado eles pensar que é mais
importante direção velocidade que quando
fala mova-se que é mais importante
a direção ea velocidade é um conflito
aqui porque se você tiver indo muito
rápido que o lugar errado você está cada
vez mais longe no caminho certo ou seja
a primeira reflexão que fica não existe
nada mais perigoso que o idiota motivado
é um perigo
o idiota se motivar porque é melhor você
ter ficado mais ameno mais devagar porém
tem gente que se esconde dentro da sua
lerdeza tem gente que confunde paciência
com certeza tem de falar senão filhos o
paciente
devagar e sempre não você é lerdo há uma
diferença entre paciência certeza
paciência você paga o seu melhor mas
respeita o tempo de conhecimento das
coisas
o levo ele só espera ele tem a falsa
esperança do verbo esperar não do verbo
esperançar tem gente que espera que 2009
seja diferente também espero que seja 18
tem que ficar esperando se aquelas
pessoas que vivem em um final de ano sem
falando agora vai sair agora vai
eu percebi que eu me mover com
eficiência o recurso que eu usei tá na
palma da minha mão preciosos minutos
preciosos que a gente vai estar junto
eu quero continuar nessa que tem algum
lugar dentro de você que às vezes você
ainda não percebeu mostra o
comprometimento a mão legal
agora olha você pra ela eu já vi que
você tem uma legal a mantém cinco dedos
se você não tiver um se sinta excluído
dessa palestra
tá mas era pra ter cinco dedos
o primeiro dedo e ouvir que o que me
ensinou a me envolver com eficiência tá
na palma da mão
primeiro ele simboliza o que é nosso
cotidiano como este mostra o dedo pra
alguém simbolismo que positividade olha
que legal nossa idéia é acertar seu lado
para assim olha a cara de pastel que
você faz de novo é o cara de pastel você
faz às vezes estava há cinco anos e
mostra se devo ou não eu não sei se tem
um tendão que liga do dedo não só que
não dá para você mostrar se deduz irão
acompanhar um sorriso não tem como
acreditar
fedor mas a gente pergunta como é que
está a ser beleza
a primeira coisa positividade agora
vamos dividir que o joio do trigo que é
uma pessoa positiva que uma pessoa
negativa às vezes muda em forma
compreensiva desafiador uma pessoa
positiva
ela reconhece todos os problemas que têm
mas só discutir a solução eo negativo
para cada solução que a vida traz ele
gosta de falar do problema
se você tem o hábito de discutir sobre o
problema você negativo se você tem um
ato de reconhecer os que têm mais fala
como é que ele pode fazer diferente
eu dou só levou dois revólveres busca
uma idéia só que é uma linha muito tênue
entre algo que fica escondido dentro da
falsa produtividade uma linha muito
tênue que o alienado a pessoa que
reconhece os problemas que têm mais
preferem não falar nele deixa q deus
além do cuidado se você recusa o
problema que você tem você dar tempo a
ele é como se tivesse comido um leão
ele vai convocar maior maior e matte
leão sempre quando for pequena analogia
de um grande problema positividade do
incidente significa que a positividade
do clássico que a gente usa pra quê
apontará mostrar à direção para onde
está indo pergunta do milhão pra quem
está aqui presente ou em casa porque
está assistindo aqui você está aqui
presente porque se veio tudo se quer
agora troca você tem seis minutos aqui ó
pra falar que o plano de vida aqui para
o mundo inteiro está transmitindo
qualquer
tem gente que se encaminharia se eu
falar agora você agora tem cinco minutos
ver em 3d fazem calma deixa eu pensar
quem já estaria formulando um plano
agora não tá bom eu tenho cinco minutos
e eu vou falar tem que ter clareza do
que você quer clareza do que você quer a
primeira coisa então direcção primeiro
lugar em produtividade
o segundo direção e vamos pro um dedo
internacional
eu quero que você tira a carga emocional
de cima dele o que ele significa na
sociedade eu quero só ver a anatomia
primeiro quero ver se não se tem esse
deles olha a autonomia deles o dedo
médio mostra dentro de um caiaque também
não seria legal isso
o dedo médio agora olha que incrível
mostra se ele ficar ao seu lado mostra
que tem o dedo médio para ela para a
famosa praça eu tenho um dedo médio
mostra legal é libertador é o benefício
liberta a demora do médio parece que a
gente já for esse dentro de uma
inteligência que não tem tamanho
esse dedo no nosso cotidiano significa
algo ruim mas o fundamento dele
significa quando você está debatendo com
alguém quer uma diferença em conflito e
confronto conflito quando estão
argumentando mas as duas querem que tudo
se resolva confronto quando você quer lá
outra parte
o conflito já que a evolução e confronto
guerra
temos que ter conflito confronto nunca
só que começa uma dica pra todo mundo
não se engaje a tentar fazer com que
alguém que compreenda se está fazendo
força para não entender o que se está
discutindo uma pessoa e esse dedo ele
aparece uma hora muito mística quando
você está debatendo com essa pessoa ela
tá e engajada não de compreender sem
falar que quer saber
aqui tem horas na vida que você não seja
necessariamente mostrar mais ligado
dentro de você que tem muita gente está
muito preocupado com o que o outro vai
achar outro tem gente que deixa a
opinião de um terceiro se torne a sua
realidade tem medo do julgamento eles
têm medo da crítica da condenação por
saber que atitude o que você quer
tem uma estratégia pra você não ser
condenado na vida não queria nada não
faça nada se torna ninguém fique parado
por isso se você ficar parado você não
se mover
você não vai incomodar ninguém mais
importante liga esse dedo
esse dedo representa dona ivone carneiro
minha avó fala que a gente usa o aliança
neste dele tem a ver que liga no coração
não sei se é verdade achei tão fofo que
eu me peguei na época o placar e nem me
conta e se der pra mim significa valores
para mim é preferível atrasar a vitória
do que profissional valor
eu prefiro vencer mais devagar do que
ganhar rápido a qualquer custo
eu percebi como eu sou casado
há 12 anos com esposa maravilhosa tenho
dois filhos que sucesso igual fidelidade
quem é que é casado ou é noivo ou namora
gente quem tem alguém na vida em que
levantou o braço nas três possibilidades
em morelia casey que tenha um caso agora
é legal você tem alguém na vida
experimente fazer isso o sucesso golf de
idade como assim k experimenta hoje ao
final desse grande evento você chegar na
pessoa que você jurou amor eterno
você chama ela de um pedido secreto que
todo casal tem um filho secreto mas
aquela voz em que só você sabe fazer e
faz o seguinte você tem culhão amor eu
te amo tanto sabe o ted foi
transformador também tem 10 foi
transformador para mim eu te amo tanto
mas tanto mas tanto que 98 por cento do
tempo que ele esteve junto eu fui fiel a
você sabe se todos 98% dele foi só você
na minha cabeça
quem acha que acabou com o casamento
nacional porque sucesso como fidelidade
só de 25% ou é ou não é uma entrega
total ou qualquer outro número não
importa mais
ou és em 10 a 14 25 e 86 98 por isso a
pergunta que fica decidido é que outras
coisas você dorme na sua cabeça às vezes
no sábado à noite que não atua meta que
não tem um plano que não aquilo que você
quer o teu caminho ao estado aquilo que
te faz bem aquilo que você não consegue
um minuto sem pensar a respeito porque
tem gente que prefere ver certo do que
viver feliz tem estratégia vivo certo
agradar a todos - assim mesmo o dedo
menor mas não menos importante é o dedo
de caos e as pessoas menosprezam
geralmente o que é melhor
pessoas menosprezam realmente
pequenininho
o detalhe é que vai fazer a diferença
levante a mão por gentileza mágica
levantada levante um pouco mais
olha que o fenômeno porque se levantou
assim logo de cara na primeira tentativa
simples assim tem gente que é tão
negativo é o negativo é que quando chega
nessa dinâmica levante a mão bem alto a
gente fala tem necessidade mesmo gente
levantar
não vejo necessidade nenhuma agora
levantar não é esse aí vai sofrer um
pouco
então se você tiver pouca atividade sob
a direção tinha atitude na hora
importante da sua vida tiver valores
muito bem conduzido e guiados que vão
ser o grande norte a sua vida e você
valorizar todos os detalhes da sua
caminhada
você vai se mover com muito mais
eficiência porque não peço a deus para
guiar os passos e não está disposto a
mover os pé e quando você olhar pra tua
mão eu quero que você perceba não dele
que está faltando aqui ó
só falta aqui ó obrigado a todos